can I be with bosses demons
if I knew the quantum state of
lightyear pubic region around us and I
knew exactly what everything was doing
and I knew all the laws of physics and I
think computational power and I did not
know the laws of thermodynamics or
economics or biology could I evolve it
forward just using the laws of physics
and get the inevitably right answer or
will they get the wrong answer to the
distribution of matter at the end of
that to get to within the theory what
theory talks about mean is etherion
complete okay you see but I got the
impression that you couldn't because of
basic things in physics like the
coherence and normal Gallagher no I
don't think okay I mean it's just it's a
quantum mechanical version of Laplace's
daemon but the Schrodinger equation you
know this is deterministic it says what
will happen we can talk about wave
functions collapsing in probabilities
but I think that's a red herring for
this argument it's still you know so I
will predict the probability of it
happening rather than it happening or we
can be many worlds or whatever I'm just
saying is the theory complete or is
there something that we get wrong by not
knowing the higher-level description it
makes sense to say I have a big computer
I simulated at the end I have a
distribution of matter I look at it I
see The Economist's right but the what I
think bothers people is relationship
between theories not the relationship
you know not building a simulation and
running through but we want to know if
our theory of psychology is consistent
with our theory of quantum field theory
so the rifles a drivable strong right we
don't want to know those if those two
theories are the same it may be the case
that we that we won't know now it might
be said every good science big
scientific theory eventually we can sort
of see how the construction will go no
you're avoiding my easy question
my easy question is is is if you run the
simulation and answer and is the answer
right if you if you run the simulation
and use at the end you get the
distribution of matter and you see the
economists I think is there anyone who
disagrees with that I don't think so
that's okay sorry sorry let me give you
an answer let me give you a tentative
answer because again I this is I want to
actually see what you think about this
so from the stuff that I read recently
one possible answer would be yes you get
a an accurate description of the
positions or properties of matter at
that level you get no information at all
about let's say the temperature and
pressure which some of that matter of
transitions to from from liquid to the
vapor because for that you know to get
that you need additional boundary
conditions you need something else no I
mean I think that any boundary condition
I might need is included in my I just
had a million light years across I have
right so I never my only predict
predicting of one year in the future
there's no boundary conditions that can
possibly affect it so so ultimately
let's say that happened the lobos's
diamond is back there a million years
back I've got this this cubic line here
I look down here and I say this this is
this looks very busy to me so the boss
is demoness is predicted that I think
that this is very busy that's that's
your playing what what is it what does
it mean you think I have the sixth
experience on this rug has got so much
stuff on it yeah that's nice it's
aesthetically troubling to me you know
now so Laplace is demon is gonna gonna
explain that piece well I didn't use the
word explain no no what's he gonna do is
he gonna predict that that's exactly
take the location of every molecule in
there but oh I understand that I'm not
worried about the molecules in the room
I'm
I'm worried about that I just thought
that's thought what that plays a queen
in your your story so so what it means
is that there are interesting two things
to say about the world that that
description that the losses daemon is
using doesn't know about that I think
it's a definite interesting part of
emergence in my mind the way to find the
laws of the special science is the way
to find the laws of economics and
biology and even chemistry or
solid-state physics is not to take the
standard model of particle physics and
renormalize okay everyone agrees on that
and nevertheless we can experimentally
in by being scientists and being by
almost all the scientists in the world
you know do things other than particle
physics and find regularities that are
interesting and true and useful and
nevertheless it remains true that I
don't need to know about those
regularities to answer questions that
can be phrased in the language of the
fundamental theories there's an old
example of mine which I think is apt
here where we imagine a prediction
contest between Laplace's daemon and an
Earthling and how the plazas daemon can
actually interact with the earthling to
have a contest it's tricky because
separately because Laplace is daemon
we're supposing does not conceive of the
earthling as an investigator okay
because this is just a it's a mass of
atoms but for something to do we have to
give me that bit and that's oh they're
gonna have a prediction contest the
earthling picks up the phone in a phone
rings everything picks it up and says oh
you're coming for dinner fine will you
stop off and pick up a bottle of wine on
the way home great see within the hour
click now the Laplace is demon with its
total knowledge predicts this incredible
trajectory of the person who's on the
other end of the phone
stopping in traffic starting and traffic
stopping at a barber shop buying a
bottle of wine to that event and
arriving at this destination and
bringing the bottle of wine in that's
the same prediction that the earthling
makes namely there's gonna be a bottle
of wine sitting on this table in one
hour so
Laplace is demon has a problem given
that the Laplace a demon is working it
out just from the physics he sees and he
even predicted that the earthling would
make this prediction but he knows how he
made his prediction he had to track
every bloody atom in the whole universe
practically in order to predict this and
he can see that the earthling doesn't
have access to all that information so
the earthen capacity to win the bat to
make the same prediction is gonna look
like magic to him unless he has the
intentional stance and can see that the
earthling is an agent that has beliefs
and desires that understands the
language is being said that trusts the
person on the fall and so forth if you
don't have that level we were both going
to make the same prediction but but the
but the Laplace is demon is going to be
baffled by how and I'll put it sort of
stronger to the the Laplace a demon can
given that incredible infinite capacity
can predict where and when Earthlings
make successful distinctions the
predictions but but it's not gonna have
any what any resources within the
theoretical vocabulary that he has to
mean of Y and and - you have to do each
one seriatim has to do each one atom by
atom there were no generalizations that
allows the Laplace's daemon to say which
Earthlings make successful predictions
when yeah I mean Laplace is neither has
well that was on intentional time that
was the premise that was the premise
well certainly I was only gonna make a
smaller point that he or she doesn't
need all that he can imagine Oh flossing
demon that only speaks the language of
the wavefunction at night but he will be
missing something that's that one well
the kind of thing that he is missing is
an ability to make efficient predictions
but he's not missing any ability to make
predictions about what he has access
prediction surely the efficiency of the
prediction is partly a consequence of
the way the world is actually structured
all right there there is frequency with
demon always knows when that happens
yeah the fauces demon is better but way
less efficient and I think that you know
just saying it would make great sound if
we makes it sound like like denigrating
it to say it's just efficiency but
efficiency is really amazingly important
it's a true regularity of the world and
fact and in fact if the if the laplacian
demon is reflective the laplacian demon
if the plasma and demon itself has a
concept of efficiency it's gonna realize
that there are some parts of the world
that is predicting that has incredibly
efficient ways of making predictions
they're not perfect but they're much
better than a coin toss and that it will
be a puzzling fact for which the
laplacian demon does not have the
resources to answer to explain why that
efficiency should exist
need a concept of efficiency as you had
said it's going to seem like magic to
the process demon and therefore if he's
rational at all he's going to want to
explain it as we shouldn't want to
explain it why is it so efficient what
seems to be a course you cannot leave it
as a raw fact exactly does that be
missing something big about what's going
down there do you think that supports I
think that supports money
you